hi everyone i'm brady i'm the guy who
makes the videos here on 60 symbols and
this is a quick message to tell you
about a new channel we're starting
called deep sky videos i think it might
interest the average 60 symbols viewer
it features a lot of familiar
faces and some new ones we're going to
start uploading the full videos in
january but we're filming now and to
give you a bit of a taste i thought i'd
show you something i filmed the other
night with one of britain's best
astrophotographers
and it just goes to show everything
doesn't always go according to plan
shouldn't take us too long to get
another image
m33 with a nice satellite trail across
it as you've just seen what's happening
so that's a satellite trail some piece
of um hardware in orbit maybe a spy
satellite or something like that has
just happened to pass through the field
of view of where our telescope's
pointing which is rather unlucky because
the telescope's actually looking at a
fairly small area of the sky you see the
galaxy in the center there we're doing
battle with the light pollution here big
time here's the center of the galaxy the
m33 is a spiral galaxy but because the
sky conditions aren't good all we can
really see at the moment is the central
core of it just this faint fuzzy white
area in the middle
another satellite trail okay what we
have here is a 60 second exposure of the
galaxy um but it's not really improved
it that much because we're imaging
through um some some low cloud
there's a bright moon in the sky and it
really will affect these these cameras
are so sensitive but once again we've
got another satellite trail coming
through the image but one thing i find
when i'm out here imaging by pointing
the telescope at that part of the sky
and sort of south east at this time of
night early evening there does seem to
be a lot of satellites picked up by
these images and even on this uh just a
60 second exposure you can see we've got
another
another um satellite image there well i
mean the satellites can be a problem for
the deep sky imager in that um if you're
using a telescope that has quite a wide
field of view and you're taking fairly
long exposures either five minutes or
ten minutes then
at some point during that exposure it's
quite likely that satellite will be
recorded passing in front of the image
in fact a recent image that i've taken
of the andromeda galaxy with a
refracting telescope actually recorded
five satellite trails in a in a
five-minute exposure so it just gives
you a good idea of just how crowded
the skies are with all these satellites
in orbit so that's just a small taste of
what's coming from deep sky videos
but in fairness to nick i thought i
should show you some images he took
where satellites didn't get in the way
and things worked out nicely
there's going to be loads more about
these types of images and lots of things
from the depths of space on deep sky
videos i hope maybe i've tempted you to
subscribe
you can also follow us on twitter and
facebook
all the details are down below in the
video description